what's up guys my name is Samuel Leeds
and in this video I'm gonna be giving
you the truth about passive income now
this is kind of like a flipside of some
of the negatives and preconceptions
around passive income that you may have
heard from other people or even heard
things from me and thought passive
income is it really that easy so as
someone who's been in business now for
12 years
who's accumulated a lot of properties
who's worked in business who's written
books and been preaching passive income
for many years I want to give you the
actual reality and my hands-on
experience of passive income if you like
my videos please do subscribe turn the
notification belt on and you need to
destroy the like button okay so if the
little blue thumbs up boy if it's not
blue that's bad you need the button to
be blue throughout this video I'd have
really appreciate that thank you so much
so first thing I want to say about
passive income is this passive income is
hard if you want to create a lot of
passive income and I hear people talking
about creating millions of pounds worth
of passive income in my opinion that is
not impossible but it is very very
difficult to achieve if you want to
achieve 2,000 pound a month that's fine
2,000 pounds a month in passive income
very attainable you want to achieve
500,000 pounds a year or millions of
pounds a year in passive income that's
going to take a particular kind of
person so you take a very long time it's
gonna be a lot of hard graft and work so
that's the first thing I'll say about
passive income next thing I'll say about
passive income is this passive income
doesn't necessarily mean you have to do
absolutely nothing for it the definition
of passive income is income that's
coming with little to no maintenance by
yourself
they don't mean absolutely nothing so
yes it's gonna give you a totally
different type of lifestyle but in my
experience most of the passive income
streams I've got coming in not all of
them some of them are completely passive
where I do nothing but normally speaking
you're gonna have to tweak a few things
here and there stay on top of there
every week or to check what's going on
check in with people that is just normal
okay so that's just setting the
expectations right third thing I want to
say about passive income is this don't
just pursue passive income alone
massive income is great massive income
is also great if you're trying to
combine passive income and massive
income and that's all you're focusing on
my advice would be active income there's
nothing wrong with working for money
there's nothing wrong with trading your
time for money as long as when you do it
you're using the profits that you'll
make in to then put into investments to
then point to something that's going to
give you passive income it's like rowing
a boat you want to oars you want to be
working for money you want to be trading
your time for money and making massive
income for sure but then take the money
and then you want to row the other or as
well which is putting it into passive
income streams so it's massive its
passive is massive its passive you're
being an entrepreneur over here where
you're doing things like deal packaging
deal packaging is trading your time for
money you're finding deals you're
selling them to investors deal packaging
getting money and then you're putting it
into investments and building your
passive income over here sell a deal
invest in a deal sell a few deals invest
in a deal and that's how you need to get
wealthy in my experience so that's my
overall thoughts on passive income I
hope you found this useful passive
income is real it does exist one more
thing I'll say is a bonus piece of
content you might think right now if
you're working on the job for two three
four five thousand pounds a month and
you're working really hard and you
thinking oh my gosh I wish I just had a
few thousand pounds in passive income
and then I could just lie on a beach
forever I promise you this you become
financially free you will not want to
stop working you will get bored well I'm
going to beach forever
when I became financially free I climbed
Kilimanjaro I learned to play different
instruments I wrote an album I went a
lot on holidays I traveled but believe
me you're gonna get bored so enjoy what
you do that's the most important advice
I can say find something that you love
doing because if you love doing it it
won't feel like work if you want to see
more about passive income you want to
learn more about property you want to
learn more about Finance subscribe to
the channel thank you for having the
blue thumb-up I know you liked the video
I trust that you did that and I'll see
you next time